Always wash your hands. Always. Be in a constant
state of washing your hands. I'm washing my
hands right now.
Hi everybody, Trace here for DNews. Simple
question: Do you wash your hands after using
a public bathroom? If you’re like the American
adults surveyed in 2010, 96 percent of you
said yes. Which means 6 percent of you are
liars. That’s according to a 2013 Michigan
State study published in the Journal of Environmental
Health. Go green!
To be fair, you can’t expect people to self-report
accurately, especially if it’s on something
like handwashing, where we all feel the pressure
to be hygienic. And a 90 percent wash rate
is still pretty darn spiffy. But the bigger
question is: how many people wash their hands
correctly?
That’s the real answer that the Michigan
State study was searching for. To find it
they had a dozen research assistants post
up in bathrooms across Lansing and take notes.
As long as they didn't go to the Landshark,
amirite guys? The assistants were trained
in the art of stealth so as not to draw suspicion.
They watched over 3,700 bathroom goers and
organized their results by gender, age, time
of day, bathroom cleanliness, hand dryer availability,
time spent washing, sink type, pretty much
every variable you can think of.
According to their findings: 10 percent of
people didn’t wash, 23 percent of people
just wetted their hands and called it a day,
and 67 percent of people used soap. But here's
the thing: just using soap isn’t enough.
The goal here is to kill bacteria, and to
do that you’ve got to give your hands a
good long scrub. The researchers found only
5 percent of people washed their hands with
soap for 15 seconds or longer. If 15 seconds
sounds like overkill, the Centers for Disease
Control actually recommend scrubbing for twenty
seconds. Their guidelines for safe washing
encourage you to hum happy birthday from beginning
to end twice, as though the tune wasn’t
agonizing enough once a year. But to reiterate,
only 5 percent of people wash their hands
correctly using this one weird trick.
That trick, is using soap. Why soap? Because
of it's unique properties. A soap molecule
looks like a snake. The head is a carboxylate
that loves water and the tail is a hydrocarbon
chain that hates it! When these molecules
are mixed with H2O, they form little structures
called micelles, with the heads on the exterior
and the tails inside, kind of like circling
the wagons. Like most things in nature, they
are polar, they carry an electrical charge.
Since they're all negatively charged, the
micelles repel each other distributing throughout
the water. When these micelles come in contact
with grease and oil, the hydrocarbon part
(on the inside) grabs the oil, trapping it,
lifting it off your skin and suspending it
in the water so it can be washed away. This
behavior allows you to scrub the microbes
under the dirt into oblivion, and is also
why alcoholic hand sanitizers aren’t as
effective at killing germs on dirty and greasy
hands.
You may be tempted then to splurge for antibacterial
soap -- but though it sounds good, it’s
actually the worst. The key ingredient, triclosan,
does kill 99 percent of bacteria, but 42 years
of FDA research has shown it’s not much
more effective at killing harmful bacteria
than regular soap and friction. And a side-effect
of the unnecessary overuse of antibacterial
triclosan is bacteria have adapted to be resistant
to it. Thus, there's no way to kill those
superbugs effectively when we need to. Like
when people get sick from diseases that could
have been prevented from washing their hands
in the first place. 31 percent of diarrhea
cases and 21 percent of respiratory illnesses
like colds can be avoided just with some scrubbing.
See, washing your hands is a win against harmful
bacteria on every level, and it feels good.
Just remember, stick to regular soap, give
your hands a nice long scrub, and don’t
forget to get under the fingernails where
most microbes live.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
You may be freaked out about germs but that’s
because you’re lacking in civic pride. I
have more about your city’s microbes here.
Go local spores team!
So do you scrub enough or do you live life
on the edge?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more, and I will see you next time on DNews.